(TV audience cheering)
What, did you raid my fridge?
Yeah, you got something
you wanna tell us, Todd?
How far along
is the pregnancy?
(mocking laughter)
No, I'm stress eating
right now.
Just downloaded
a new dating app
and...I have, like,
zero messages.
Let me see your profile picture.
I look great.
(record scratching)
#
Yeah, that's weird.
Uh, why'd you retouch your abs?
Did you re-edit one nipple
higher than the other?
No. Abs, yes, but I didn't touch
the nipples, all right.
And plus, you guys don't know
anything about relationships.
Uh...I'm married.
Okay, okay, here's
what you need to do.
You just gotta change
that picture.
-Absolutely.
-Yeah.
-What?
-You need a picture with people
in it to show
that you're fun and normal.
What about Halloween, huh?
Yeah, we had
some cool pictures from that.
It's an oldie
but a goodie.
A classic.
Here we go, here we go,
here we go.
Wait, wait, wait,
should we wait for Todd?
Right now we just look like
a sad salad.
-Um, no.
-Hey, we gotta move.
I think I hit, like,
a parked car or something.
Uh, but, Todd, where's
your burger patty costume?
Yeah, what's with
the bows?
Eh? Right?
-I'm a gift to all women.
-Todd!
-I hope you saved the receipt.
-No, I didn't.
Dude, you ruined
the whole burger costume.
-C'mon, it's gonna be great.
-Oh my gosh.
It's gonna be great.
Free drinks all night,
because I am gonna be getting
free drinks.
-Shut up, Todd!
-No one's gonna--
-Here we go, here we go.
-I'm gonna go low.
Fine, go low.
-Mmm...nuh-uh.
-Okay.
Okay, they say that
you should use
a profile pic
that shows your interests.
Mm, mm, I could do
my fantasy football draft,
I'm the commissioner.
What is that?
Shows a lot of leadership.
You--you kinda like to hike.
Remember--remember
the hiking trip?
-Yeah!
-Okay guys, ready?
Wait, hold on.
Todd!
Seriously? Uck.
What are you--
-Every time.
-Oh my God.
-He's giving us some butt.
-What are you doing?
Just keep--keep snapping,
it's fine, guys.
Oh, it's cold!
-Um...
-Hm, no.
You're just afraid
of the male form.
That's a direct pec pic.
Okay, okay, hold on,
I got this.
Vegas, okay.
I might be the only one
who remembers it.
But you looked great
that night.
Milo, Milo, take another one,
take another one.
Okay, I'm sorry, I think
there's a misunderstanding.
Yeah, we asked you
to take a picture of us,
not be in the picture.
Semantics, semantics!
I can't find any pictures
where you're not hanging out
with club girls.
-So what?
-That's a giant red flag, okay?
No one wants to date
a guy that hangs out
with other hot chicks.
I got it.
Use this one.
Aww, me and your grandma's cat?
Yes! You're relaxed,
you're smiling with teeth.
There's a cat!
There's a cat.
My heart is melting.
Okay, I'll do that.
But, um...should I use
my real name?
-Yes.
-Absolutely.
What did you write?
I wanted to get "Little Dipper"
but it was taken,
because I like to be
the little spoon.
That's awful.
It's terrible.
You guys want any of this?
I--no thank you.
Yeah, no.
I'm gonna eat all of it.